So let's see if we know how to use multiple predictors and
combine their decisions. Suppose that we have a program in
which a 2-bit predictor works just fine for 95% of our instructions.
A PSHARE predictor works just fine for the same 95% of the instructions,
plus it also works fine for 2%. That this 2-bit predictor doesn't cover.
So, overall, it works fine for 97% of full instructions, but the 95% here and
here overlap. A GSHARE predictor, again, works just fine for
the same 95% that all the other predictors are just fine for.
Plus it works fine for the other 3%. So overall, it's 98% accurate.
95 of those are the same as the 2-bit predictor. But the three that
it covers in addition to that are not the same. But the three that it covers in
addition to that are different from the 2% that the PSHARE predictor covers.
So together, these three predictors should be able to correctly predict
all instructions. So the question for you is how do we combine them.
So the overall predictor that we will use is a, what kind of predictor.
That chooses between a what kind of predictor and what kind of predictor. And
this last predictor here, itself, will choose between what kind, and
what kind of predictor. Instead of writing in the names of the predictors.
Just select among the following. So for each of them say if it's A, B, C, D or
E. A is the 2-bit predictor. B is the PSHARE predictor.
C is the GSHARE predictor. D is the Tournament predictor.
E is a Hierarchical predictor. And F, is the Return Address Stack.
So again, for each of these five boxes, put which letter corresponds,
to the predictor, that is the right answer for that box.